we're now joined from Buckinghamshire by
his main rival the man who is currently
in number 11 the conservative Chancellor
Sajid Javid thank you for being on the
program today you're gonna be laying out
your manifesto later what should we
expect from it well I'm very excited
about the launch and what you'll see is
that we're go ahead get brexit done
we're gonna unleash the potential of our
whole country and we'll be setting out
in some detail about how we are the only
party that will be able to deliver
bricks it with a deal within weeks of
taking office we're going to start that
process before Christmas certainly
completed by the end of January but it
will then give us the the opportunity to
really focus on what I call the people's
priorities your more focus on the NHS on
our great schools and on tackling crime
with 20,000 more police officers you're
also promising this idea of a triple tax
lock I promise not to increase income
tax national insurance or v80 and yet
you're paying to spend billions of
pounds more on some of those things that
you just mentioned in that answer you're
the Chancellor how now do these sums add
up well we are very clear we want to
help people with the cost of living
wherever we can so earlier this week we
set out our plans to cut taxes to cut
national insurance for 31 million people
helping the lowest page you can add a
most and and well if I answer the
question about the tax look and I'll
show you exactly how it adds up we are
also announcing today this as you say
the triple tax log which is our
commitment giving more financial
security to hard-working people that
under a conservative majority government
though the rates of tax in the free
biggest taxes national insurance income
tax and v80 will not rise and they can
be absolutely certain of that and of
course contrast that to jeremy corbyn's
plans of a tax rise of around two
thousand four hundred pounds per person
yeah it's a huge difference in our
approach to helping people in terms of
their numbers in terms of the numbers
and how do they add up I'm sorry two
thousand four hundred per person does
Labour's thus latest plans Labour's
plans for a tax increase of 2004
hundred pounds we've just heard Labor's
panel MacDonald on average so into in
terms of our plans in terms of you asked
me how do they add up we will set out
today alongside our manifesto published
at exactly the same time a very detailed
costings document it will take every
additional cost that set our manifesto
every single thing with his tax or
anything else and we will set had
exactly Harrigan funded for their
lifetime of the Parliament it will in
fact be the most detailed most
transparent cost things that has ever
been published in British electoral
history by any party and everyone will
be able to see that for themselves okay
well we look forward to poring through
the detail a little later today when
that is released we know that you're
planning to borrow more because she told
us she said that you're happy to
borrowed an extra twenty billion pounds
a year now you of course works closely
with George Osborne in the Treasury when
it was all about deficit reduction it
was all about belt tightening it was all
about balancing the books now you're
about to turn on the spending taps now
you're about to borrow billions of
pounds more I mean you're really
comfortable with this like people who
have been suffering for ten years
through austerity gonna be thinking what
was the point of fact if the deficits
just gonna start merrily ticking back up
again we've had in the in the last ten
years we've had a real decade of
recovery and that has meant that we've
had to of course try to bounce them the
nation's books and that's exactly what
we've been doing but I think everyone's
understood when you're living beyond
your means when you're boring in an
irresponsible way which is exactly what
the last game from what government was
doing the last Labour government then
we've got to move forward bounce the
books but also do what we can to get the
economy going and support that dynamic
your free enterprise economy it's as a
result of those actions that we've taken
today we've got strongly connect
fundamentals we've got more people
employed than ever before we've got an
unemployment rate at a forty four year
low but because the economy is strong we
can afford and as we set this out in
very clear what we call fiscal rules we
were balanced day to day spending and we
work instill afford to borrow up to a
limit for investment in economic in
structure to make improvements
especially in productivity in our
country so investment in Road in rail in
fiber optic connections we're announcing
today for example a 2 billion pothole
filling program you know these are the
kind of things that we can do to have
that infrastructure revolution and it
very importantly and this is a huge
distinction between us and labor we are
still clear that even with our program
our program for investment that debt
will be lower at the end of this
Parliament than at the start of
Parliament with Lane their plans for 1.2
trillion debt will be absolutely utterly
out of control I just want to come back
on some of the point you were making
about the economy being in a strong
state at the minute which allows you to
do this to loosen the purse strings
Moody's one of the world's big credit
ratings agencies just downgraded Britain
because it's worried about the economic
future last month the government had its
highest October budget deficit in five
years debt is 1.8 trillion pounds I mean
people will be looking at this and this
was before the election spending pledges
that everyone is talking about and
thinking what was the point of austerity
well so you mentioned the credit rating
agency I mean first of all the main
reason they gave was the uncertainty and
the paralysis in our Parliament so one
of the best things that we can do for
our country to move the economy forward
is to remove that uncertainty with our
brexit deal which as I say can happen
within months and and secondly when you
look at the nation's finances we are in
a strong position to invest more but as
long as we take a prudent approach and
keep day-to-day spending under control
we've done that now with labour and you
just had John McConnell on you know they
haven't even done a proper costings
document at all even after publishing
their manifesto they're throwing out new
policies like confetti with billions of
billions of consequential costs and it
should show you that with labor you're
spending boring and debt will be
absolutely out of control you know every
labor government has left our country
with an economic crisis with this lot
it won't take years as a labor govern
ormally does to have that crisis they'll
do it within months if Jeremy Corbyn is
standing outside Downing Street you
imagine that nightmare for
waking up to that there will be a crisis
by Christmas well let's let's talk about
your own policy style shall we I know
it's in election mode we'll all keen to
attack the other parties and but if you
look at Labour's pet manifesto you might
not like what's in it but it is a
radical program for change and I have to
say if you look at the Conservative
Party manifesto some people will be left
wondering what is it that the
Conservative Party's actually stands for
do you stand for anything more than
basically just spending a little more
but a bit less than Labor boring more
but a little bit less than Labor where
is the radical vision for change in this
manifesto
well you mentioned Labour's is radical
radical for sure you're radical in in
being absolutely utterly irresponsible
with the nation in our future so what's
the conservative manifesto absolutely so
you'll see our manifesto in detail in a
few hours from now but you'll see first
and your foremost but the reason we're
having this election is because we need
to move on and get brexit done and we'll
set out our plans for that whilst
maintaining a close economic
relationship with our European friends
and I think people want to see us move
ahead with that we'll be focusing on
those things that really matter to
people on the doorstep you are a great
NHS making sure we can fund it properly
with an extra thirty four billion pounds
a year we're going to provide 14 billion
pounds of the next three year for our
schools 20,000 more police officers more
folks on child care a new National
Skills Fund we're announcing today three
billion pounds for individuals and small
businesses to retrain people you're a
boring Hospital car parking charges for
most people and also a green revolution
it will be the most green manifesto any
party has ever published with a six
billion pound fund for example for homes
especially two million social homes to
make sure they're properly insulated and
they set for the future the concept of
parties always in many people's minds
stood for low taxes you've described
yourself previously as a low tax guy or
the kind of person who has a picture of
Margaret Thatcher on your wall and you
said you've said a concept of conference
that it cut to inheritance tax is on
your mind
is it still on your mind why don't you
wait and see
what's the detail in the manifest though
in terms of big tax what he said with
we've what we've already set out some of
our big tax changes and our tax changes
are absolutely focused on the
lowest-paid and that's why we focused on
national shorts with our ambition to get
it to twelve thousand five hundred
pounds in terms of the threshold meaning
a tax cut for almost five hundred pounds
for hardworking people would you like
stamp duty to come down I'm not going to
set out a future budget right now should
we be lucky enough to win this election
then I will have my first budget and I
will certainly talk about other taxes at
that time and you want so it's
interesting you talk about other taxes
you are keen then to prioritize cutting
taxes in the future if you manage to
stay in your job after this election we
will we will cut taxes whenever we can
afford it whenever it is prudent for the
country and I think we've shown that in
the last ten years how we can both cut
taxes and invest in the great public
services and the reason we're able to do
that as a country is hugely important
and people really do understand this
when you talk about it it's because we
have a strong economy it's a strong
economy a dynamic free-market economy
that backs business that does this you
know again with Labor's plans they have
earned for the biggest tax increase ever
the most punitive tax regime for
corporates that's not my view that's the
view of the IFS and now let's just talk
about brexit quickly because of course
one of the first things you'll do is
you've already told us if you manage to
win the election is to try and push that
withdrawal agreement through before
Christmas now your deputy wishy CMAC has
said that no dual planning would resume
after the election if the Conservatives
win so is it's no deal back on the table
well at the early risk of no deal is if
there's not a conservative majority I
think that's self-evident you know if we
have a majority we've got a deal it's
ready to go literally ready to go and
we'll bring it back as we say today
before Christmas it'll be done by
January and then there is no prospect of
no deal but if we don't win if there is
a Labour victory and Corwin Sturgeon
Alliance or a hung parliament the risk
of a No Deal is back and and the country
doesn't want to see that we've been
through that and as a country we want to
move on with a deal this
good for Britain it's good for our
European friends and we can then focus
on so much else I mean you say that and
the risk of No Deal would go if that
goes through it
we may be knit slightly different no
deals Naruto no trade deal sonare
perhaps because of course you've set a
very tight deadline if you win the
election to negotiate a new trader with
the EU if that doesn't materialize maybe
you could be setting aside some money to
try and mitigate the effects of that a
new No Deal planning I'm I'm very
confident that if we can get out if we
get a conservative majority we'll get
our deal through by the end of January
certain of that and I'm very confident
that in the time that we've said that we
will be able to agree our new economic
partnership the the principles have
already been agreed with the EU we've
already started a lot of the work
obviously it's on hold now because the
election but if we are reelected we'll
get back to that work and we can get
that deal done certainly by the end of
next year of that I have no doubt will
any money be sat inside and mitigate if
you don't manage to get that deal
through well we will the the future
economic partnership we will if we have
a conservative majority I'm confident we
will get that through I think most the
work has already been done
we're already start from a position
where the EU and the UK is aligned we
agreed on all the key principles and
let's remember you know people but just
that 100 days ago they said you wouldn't
be able to reopen the withdrawal
agreement you wouldn't be able to remove
the backstop you wouldn't be able to get
a new agreement and they were wrong
wrong wrong
and those that say you're not gonna be
able to do it they're just scare
mongering and we need to move on deliver
brexit and we're the only party that can
do that okay now historically the
relationship between Prime Minister and
Chancellor has always been a little bit
frosty bit strained at times there have
been rumours of rifts between you and
Boris Johnson so we were a little bit
relieved when he said that he would keep
you on as Chancellor after the election
if he wins well first of all we have an
absolutely fantastic relationship and
we've had that for many many years and
and you know that's not going to change
and you know I wasn't expecting to say
what he said he was asked a question and
he gave an honest answer and I love the
answer so a little bit relieved then it
was a great answer
okay Sajid Javid thank you very much for
coming on the program thank you very
much thank you having me on thank you